the vast majority of bats consume fruit
or insects like moths beetles gnats and
crickets
however some bats like this wooly false
vampire bat eat other bats the wooly
false vampire path can be found from
southern Mexico to Argentina
this particular one lives in Guatemala
its scans and surroundings and discovers
a wrinkled face bat finishing or a
freshing meal of fruit juice this will
be its last meal as is about to become a
meal itself the woolly one pounces
evoking images of Dracula by engulfing
its prey in its Cape like wings and
biting the head with four fangs in its
upper jaw to its lower and so begins a
bloodthirsty feast that will last the
entire night one that will sustain the
predator for days to come but just for
the record there are more than 1,100 bat
species out there many gentle
vegetarians
only a very very few drink blood much
less the blood of their brethren